[EXPLOSIONS]
>> Jesse: TONIGHT WE START AGAIN
IN UKRAINE WHERE RUSSIA'S
SICKENING ASSAULT ON NEIGHBOR
CONTINUES FOR A FIFTH STRAIGHT
DAY.
UKRAINIAN FORCES HAVE BEEN
SLOWING PUTIN'S ADVANCES.
IT'S DAVID VS. GOLIATH AS THEY
FOLLOW THE EXAMPLE OF THEIR
BRAVE PRESIDENT.
>> WHEN I WAS RUNNING FOR THE
PRESIDENT, I WOULD SAY THAT EACH
OF US IS THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
ALL OF US CARRY THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OUR COUNTRY,
FOR OUR BEAUTIFUL UKRAINE AND
NOW IT HAPPENED SO THAT EACH OF
SUCCESS A WARRIOR.
A WARRIOR IN HIS OR HER RIGHT
PLACE.
AND I'M SURE THAT EACH OF US
WILL WIN GLORY TO UKRAINE.
>> Jesse: TODAY THE NATION'S
SECOND LARGEST CITY OF KHARKIV
FACED INTENSE BARRAGE OF BOMBING
AS RUSSIA LOOKS TO CLOSE IN ON
THE COUNTRY'S KEY POPULATION
CENTERS.
THE MOVE MIRRORS THEIR ACTIONS
OVER THE WEEKEND WHERE SEVERAL
CITIES WERE ALSO SHELLED WITH
RUSSIAN ROCKETS.
PUTIN'S FORCES ARE BEING ACCUSED
OF TARGETING INNOCENT UKRAINIAN
NEIGHBORHOODS AS THE DEATH TOLL
CONTINUES TO RISE.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, THE WORST IS
YET TO COME.
NEW SATELLITE IMAGES SHOW A
MAJOR BUILD-UP OF RUSSIAN FORCES
JUST MILES OUTSIDE OF THE
CAPITAL CITY OF KYIV.
AND EARLIER TODAY, U.S.
OFFICIALS ADDRESSED THIS
MOVEMENT.
>> CLEARLY, WE CONTINUE TO SEE
RUSSIAN FORCES MOVE ON OR
MOVE -- TRY TO MOVE CLOSER TO SO
THEY CAN MOVE ON KYIV FROM THE
GROUND.
WE STILL ASSESS THAT THEY ARE
OUTSIDE THE CITY CENTER.
MR. PUTIN STILL HAS AT HIS
DISPOSAL SIGNIFICANT COMBAT
POWER.
HE HASN'T MOVED ALL OF IT INTO
UKRAINE BUT HE HAS MOVED A
MAJORITY OF IT HE STILL HAS A
LOT THAT HE HASN'T MOVED INTO
UKRAINE.
IT'S COMBINED ARMS.
AND IT'S NOT INSIGNIFICANT.
>> Jesse: PUTIN IS MAKING HIS
MOVE INTO KYIV WITH EVEN MORE
TROOPS WAITING IN THE WING AS
THE CITY PREPARES FOR A BLOOZY
SIEGE THIS FOLLOWS PUTIN'S
ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY THAT HE
WAS PUTTING HIS NUCLEAR FORCES
IN TO SPECIAL COMBAT READINESS.
A HEIGHTENED ALERT STATUS THAT
BRINGS BACK MEMORIES OF THE COLD
WAR.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT EVALUATED
THIS MOVE EARLIER.
>> THIS SORT OF PROVOCATIVE
RHETORIC, MORE THAN BEING
UNNECESSARY, IT IS DANGEROUS.
IT ADDS TO THE RISK OF
MISCALCULATION.
IT SHOULD BE AVOIDED.
WE ARE ASSESSING PRESIDENT
PUTIN'S DIRECTIVE AT THIS TIME.
AS I THINK YOU HAVE HEARD US
SAY.
WE SEE NO REASON TO CHANGE OUR
OWN ALERT LEVEL.
>> IF THE FACE OF ALL OF THIS
THE WORLD IS RUSHING.
U.S. AND GERMANY SEND STINGER
MISSILES TO ALLIES.
WHILE GERMANY JOINT EUROPEAN
UNION AND SWITZERLAND SAYS IT'S
GOING TO FREEZE RUSSIAN ASSETS
GOING AGAINST THE NATION'S
LONGSTANDING POSITION OF
NEUTRALITY IN CONFLICT.
LUCKILY THESE SANCTIONS ARE
HAVING ANNUAL EFFECTED AS
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY CRUMBLES.
NEARLY HALF OF RUSSIA'S CENTRAL
BANK ASSETS HAVE BEEN FROZEN IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS THE VALUE OF
RUSSIA'S CURRENCY THE RUBLE IS
IN THE GUTTER.
HYPER INFLATION COULD BE AROUND
THE CORNER MOTHER RUSSIA.
IS FIGHTING AND SANCTIONS
INTENSIFY, NEGOTIATIONS TOOK
PLACE IN BELARUS.
BUT PIECE WAS HARD TO FIND AS
RUSSIA CONTINUES TO DEMAND
OFFICIAL RECOGNITION OF ITS
CONTROL OF CRIMEA.
WHILE INSISTING UKRAINE CAN